[Música]
una orden judicial del tribunal europeo
de derechos humanos o frenó la primera
expulsión de migrantes de reino unido a
ruanda el vuelo fue cancelado tan solo
minutos antes de su despegue y pese a la
sentencia que detuvo este proceso el
gobierno británico aseguró que va a
continuar con su plan de expulsión de
estos migrantes al país de áfrica
occidental
el ejecutivo de boris johnson entonces
había alcanzado en abril un acuerdo con
ruanda por unos 148 millones de dólares
con el objetivo de detener el flujo de
peligrosos viajes por el medio del canal
de la mancha y a su vez acabar con el
modelo de negocio de las redes de los
contrabandistas de personas
organizaciones de derechos humanos y
líderes religiosos argumentan que esta
decisión es inhumana y atroz mientras
que el gobierno aseguró que no se va a
dejar disuadir por estas acusaciones y
se prepara para el siguiente vuelo y
dijo que lo va a hacer lo antes posible
para analizar entonces toda esta
situación todo este tema quiero saludar
a sergio arango nader historiador y
politólogo de la pontificia universidad
javeriana investigador en temas de
historia y también de migraciones y
relaciones internacionales sergio
gracias por estar con nosotros muy buen
día sergio las implicaciones entonces de
la cancelación de su vuelo con los
migrantes y que representa esta medida
claro raúl yo creo que esto lo tenemos
que leer en clave interna del reino
unido- claramente
el gobierno de boris johnson se enfrentó
hace unas semanas a una moción de centro
de censura incluso dentro de su partido
entonces está ante una crisis de
confianza interna ante sus propios
copartidarios y ante el público general
británico y en este marco se desarrolla
está esta medida por otro lado tenemos
que ver el discurso que boris johnson
utilizó desde que llegó al que lo llevó
al gobierno a su partido conservador es
un discurso ais las digamos hermético
hacia las fronteras desde la llegada de
migrantes y creo que es el mejor recurso
la mejor herramienta que puede tener
boris johnson para reavivar esas bases
que lo llevaron y que lo mantienen en el
poder me llama la atención si sitúe los
sondeos
unos sondeos que hicieron algunos medios
británicos casi el 40 por ciento de los
británicos estarían de acuerdo con esta
medios a que no estamos hablando de una
medida que vaya en contra totalmente la
de la opinión popular por otro lado no
uno se preguntaría pues porque ronda
cierto claro los van a mandar a ruanda
en la historia de la historia reciente
de diplomática o de o de historia de las
migraciones nos habla que ruanda siempre
se ha ofrecido para este tipo de no
siempre últimamente se ha ofrecido para
para acoger ese tipo de mecanismos en
los que no es que manden a la gente a
vivir a ruanda es que ruanda sirve como
un tercer estado mientras que se
solucionan los óseos se estudian las
solicitudes de asilo y ruanda hace unos
años incluso lo llegó a adelantar con
israel no se lleva a cabo por lo mismo
por un tema de demandas de opinión
pública pero sí es cierto que ronda a
jugar un papel ahí
ya por por un tema más como hacia el
partido conservador del reino unido
ruanda tienen los vínculos particulares
con el partido conservador el gobierno
ruandés tienen porque programas de
intercambio de desarrollo e infuncional
josh con él con el partido conservador
británico entonces creo que hay que
leerlo como en un tono en entorno como
en una línea como interna británica
además bueno todos los frentes se están
abriendo ahora con el tema del protocolo
irlanda del norte ese entonces es como
un y yo creo que es una media interna
que básicamente pues nos lleva se hace
con ese aspecto internacional y ante
todo esto y igual sergio el gobierno
johnson dijo que va a seguir y contrató
a botón contra todo pronóstico este
envío de los migrantes a ruanda
realmente lo puede hacerlo realmente
puede lograr su objetivo el gobierno
británico pues ellos están optimistas en
que lo van a lograr incluso si tú le des
los comunicados del gobierno británico
ellos dicen que ellos sabían que se van
a enfrentar a esto digamos que entraron
así sabemos que va a ser que no va a ser
fácil que tenemos
un grupo de organizaciones de derechos
humanos de abogados dedicados a este
tema que nos van a ser difícil el
proyecto pero ellos parecen estar
convencidos de que van a seguir con la
medida incluso están hablando ya de un
segundo vuelo que podría salir incluso
en los próximos días vamos a ver vamos a
ver si les funciona porque esta medida
que lo más paradójico y es que en su
digamos que de fondo hay un discurso
pues euroescéptico y
del break city muy como volver el
control hacia el reino unido que su
medial haya parado un tribunal que si
bien no hace parte de una europea si
tiene un cobijo europeo y está basado en
estrasburgo digamos a sergio que tiene
que pasar para que se reactiven o no
estos vuelos los próximos pasos que
pueda hacer el gobierno británico
digamos legalmente para que estos vuelos
tampoco no se han truncado sigamos este
segundo como no fue el primero en este
tribunal de derechos humanos en europa
puede actuar nuevamente en este segundo
yo entiendo que eso es una medida
cautelar que tomó él
el gobierno británico estaría viendo
varias vías entiendo yo una vía sería
como apelar esta medida otra sería
tramitar lo a través de una ley del
parlamento pero yo no se van a quedar
quietos creo yo ellos van a seguir con
esto porque lo que te digo es una medida
interna también para recuperar esas
bases y esa confianza que él pues el
primer ministro boris johnson y su
gobierno más cercano a pues ha ido
perdiendo como frente frente a sus
incluso como partidarios lo que quiere
implementar el gobierno con esta medida
el gobierno de boris johnson realmente
va a acabar con la migración ilegal
no yo creo que no pero pero sí es cierto
que hay que hay un aumento en los
arribos y ellos le dicen ilegales las
regulares y ellos hechos tienen un tono
como una una batería de términos que
están utilizando que es migrantes
ilegales pero son irregulares si hay un
aumento si hay un aumento
significativo en los en los cruces del
canal de la mancha yo creería que
pasaría también por una por un diálogo
con francia que parece que no se va que
no se va a desarrollar entonces uno
pensaría no por él por este caso pero
por experiencias
anteriores son otros países que estas
medidas pueden tener un impacto pero no
van a solucionar de raíz el problema
podrían ser que otros países imitar esta
medida que está que estaba haciendo que
quiere llevar a cabo reino unido-
poniendo en peligro a lo mejor a
acuerdos entre refugiados entre
migrantes también como la advierte
naciones unidas de hecho en dinamarca
pasional es una ley el precenso
parlamento que va en el mismo sentido de
encontrar un tercer país en el que los
refugiados solicitantes de asilo puedan
permanecer mientras que se les soluciona
el problema
incluso ruanda también figuraban en los
planes de dinamarca
y otros países lo han hecho no en el
mismo esquema previo australia también
piensa e implementa algo así y un día
puede poder ir un poquito más lejos
y el acuerdo que en su momento grecia
con la unión europea e hicieron de
mantener a refugiados en islas griegas
antes de que entraran al territorio
continental europeo pues va en el mismo
sentido entonces no estamos hablando de
algo que sea que no sea completamente
nuevo
pero bueno vamos a ver si les funciona
esto con ruanda pero digamos que si el
plan del gobierno de reunirnos se le da
con ruanda por la lejanía digamos por
también las críticas que tenía el
gobierno ruandés de pues no respetar los
derechos humanos a minorías lo pudiera
hacer con otro país pudiera buscar
entonces reino unido otro país a lo
mejor más cercano para poder implementar
esta medida yo mira yo creería que lo
puede hacer lo puede hacer y quién lo la
pregunta es quién quien se ofrece
también con todo este
sabemos que el acuerdo con ruanda
implicaba fondos esto era como a través
o mediante unos desembolsos del ínter
fondo
seguramente ahora en otros países
interesados pero no tengo entiendo que
antes de ruanda incluso estaban están
hablando de países como ghana o como
albania entonces
seguramente escucharemos de otros pues
vamos a ver el igual que va a pasar
vamos a ver si se lleva a cabo este
segundo vuelo sergio muchísimas gracias
por estar con nosotros en directo
américa gracias ustedes un abrazo
estamos conversando con sergio arango
nader historiador y politólogo de la
pontificia universidad javeriana en
colombia nosotros continuamos esto es
directo américa
[Música]